now we have officially numerous Outlets
have called New Hampshire for Donald
Trump that's not the big story however
of course Donald Trump won I don't see
any plausible scenar like there's no
reason for these primaries except
Democrats are trying to look man I have
so much disdain for these people that
scream M democracy while publicly
stating their intention to destroy our
Institution
and even the concept of democratic
representation meaning we democratically
elect a representative in our Republic
here's the story take a look at this so
there's Dave werman calling it for Trump
I want to play this clip Nuance bro has
the tweet from CNN Democrats are voting
for Nikki Haley tonight in New Hampshire
they're Biden supporters check this
Nikki Haley and why did you vote for
Nikki Haley uh it's a vote against Trump
um I think it would be better to have
her against Biden
in the uh elections then it would be
Trump and her do you consider yourself
generally independent Republican or
Democrat uh Democrat so when you
Undeclared you voted for Nikki Haley if
it was Nikki Haley against Joe Biden in
a general election who are you voting
for Joe Biden what is the they outright
have no they have no Scruples they have
no
morals that that is like look I say the
banality of evil a lot but this is why
I've been I've been saying Civil War man
the process be damned to these people
Republicans keep playing this game of
look how magnanimous we are and the
Democrats keep laughing and trying to
knife them in the back here's a guy
who's saying your party's process means
nothing to me I will vote for the worst
candidate imaginable knowing Republicans
will not vote for so that when I vote
for Joe Biden I can
win what what form of government would
you call that if Joe Biden wins under
those circumstances what form of
government would this man call that it's
not democracy it's not a
republic I don't know what you'd call it
I don't either it's a system of
governance where one faction sabotages
the other to install a minority less pop
like massively unpopular candidate Joe
Biden's popular was his approval rating
in the 30s it's like 33% the last time I
looked it was like extremely this guy's
a fascist is it a fascist is it I've
been sort of weighing is it
authoritarian is it totalitarian is it
fascist it literally is it's that's
exactly what it is it's the kind of
thing that uh people who have no faith
in the system of government that they
live in would do and no faith in Joe
Biden right he doesn't actually think
Joe Biden could match up against he
doesn't think yeah that's a really good
point so he's trying to say we have to
get Nikki Haley in there to help Biden
out because if it's a Biden Trump mashup
I mean he's not saying it but the the
subtext there is Biden will get defeated
by Trump there are a substantial number
of polls I think where Trump leads Biden
in the general yeah multiple out there
right now it's it's amazing though how
the left you know they will they're so
fascist all in the name of anti-fascists
and then you know they're they're so
intolerant all in the name of Tolerance
it's amazing and fascinating how their
minds work and what they do and then you
know Tim keeps mentioning you know
potential Civil War and I I
unfortunately have to agree we're I
think we're headed to that direction
hope we don't but you got to think back
uh but prior to the last Civil War um
that's when the Democrats were removing
people from the ballot then they were
removed Abraham Lincoln from The Ballot
leading up to the Civil War now to do
the
same that's a misconception the idea of
ballots being publicly uh created and
given out is a new phenomenon that did
not exist at the time of the Civil War
what happened was the Republic typically
the parties would create their ballots
here are our candidates give them out to
people and say you can basically sign it
and and drop in drop in the ballot this
is who you're voting for so it was a
Partyline ballot in I believe it was 10
Democrat States Republicans did not
issue ballots because it wasn't so there
were two big reasons one they thought it
was a waste of time and energy you are
not going to win in slaves in these
slave states that oppos but a big a big
factor was that they were concerned that
anyone who supported the Republican
Party in the abolition of slavery in
these states who was seen carrying a
ballot would
be shunned at worst beaten considering
we were in the in in The Bleeding Kansas
era where you had people like John Brown
shooting people in the face no one's
going to be seen carrying a a an Abra
Lincoln ballot in in the southern states
so they were just not released by The
they had the population so fearful
partly to to even do that because they
were afraid of what the other Democrats
would would do to them if they were to
support somebody who's in against
slavery not a single vote was cast for
Abraham Lincoln in the states that went
on to secede nobody would be caught dead
doing it because then you would be dead
so it's you know not the same as not
having you know having someone REM about
but uh because of that people have
misconstrued to Democrats removed them
from the ballot yeah they didn't have
ballots back then they had Partyline
ballots so I I I fact checked all that
and it's uh I think it's actually to a
certain degree more worrying as to you
know I think it was worse back then the
fear that the people were killing each
other you know you had Bleeding Kansas
for seven years where people were just
showing up and shooting each other John
Brown walks to a guy blasts him in the
face just kills him no questions unare
that's crazy it is where we're at now
Aaron Danielson was walking down the
street Michael Ry walked up to him and
blasted him in the chest two bullets
killing him just because Y and so it's
it's fascinating to me that we're in an
era where these stories could absolutely
uh begin but you know back to this
stuff Democrats are publicly admitting
there are no
elections that guy going on CNN and and
and and admitting this other Dem
Democratic candidates saying that
they've shut down our primary so we
can't
vote Maran Williamson is it and I think
Dean was it Dean Phillips pH Dean
Phillips of Minnesota that's right and I
got I got words spig with this guy I I
don't trust him as far as I can throw
him Mar Williamson I like they're saying
why why are we being barred from the
primary why are we why is this not being
allowed because the unip party is in
control their fascist zealots like that
man are going to make sure there is no
election they will subvert it through
every loophole imaginable so that the
least popular candidate wins all while
screaming it's everybody else who's a
fascist well didn't they also Ste the
the primary from Bernie Sanders back in
2016 yeah so I mean there just nothing
they they've done this before they are
too is like they refused to the
Democrats refused to go into New
Hampshire they tried to push them to do
South Carolina instead and then when it
looked like there were going to be
contenders they launched a Right End
campaign even though Biden's not on the
ballot and uh you know that's incredibly
rude too that's like I definitely take
your cake and eat it to situation um and
Biden has
73% of that Phillips has 20% right now
so with like how much in I mean I'm
looking at 31% 31% so as for this
Phillips guy he's got this video where
he's complaining to the Press saying you
won't cover my story you're not asking
the right questions he's he's like Biden
can't win I am trying to do this why
won't you tell the right story Laur
lomer shows up mhm she had shut up to a
Marian Williamson Event Y totally
respectfully saying I agree with you you
are right it is wrong what they're doing
they threw her out yep so this guy wants
to claim oh the media they won't cover
my story well now you've got someone
with a massive platform who is not here
to berate you but to actually amplify
your message and you throw her out and
it's because they're like oh well we
want to make sure we look good to the
press the press that won't actually
these people are and then Maran
Williamson gave her a microphone and to
basically and you could see Laura wasn't
there to to cause any issues she was
truly there as a journalist this is why
we like Maran Williamson Maran
Williamson was like oh welcome yes
please there you go have fun and they
they agreed and Marin Williamson was
like I thought you going to ask me about
how they're doing this that and she just
went off on them and I'm like good but
like this like people like Dean Phillips
he wants to win the Democratic primary
what he really wants is for the
corporate press to acknowledge Him
that's what he's complaining about Laura
Lum doesn't count he doesn't care about
her he doesn't care about what her
followers or the average person might
think he wants the New York Times to
acknowledge that he's running and he's
so frustrated I don't understand why
they won't perhaps it's because your
party is run by fascists and they are
corrupt
unsurprising but that's what you get and
this is where we're headed right now so
you know my view of this is if if people
have said this could be the last
election in fact we have a a book right
here look this just because we have all
these things just lying around hey shout
out to Steven Marsh who gets cited on
this show so often desite desite the
fact we agree on a lot of things he's uh
researched and written about Civil War
he wrote a book with Andrew Yang called
the last election I think he's wrong
though this isn't the last election the
last election was 2016 oh you think so
you think we already saw the last
legitimate election I think you could
technically argue that the last election
was 2012 interesting agreed
2016 they Democrats claimed it was
stolen and Russia stole it and then they
they tried to destroy Donald Trump false
impeachments they claimed it was stolen
for 4 years the whole time when they do
it though it's okay when they because
did we actually have an election did we
actually have an election in 2016 if
half half the country's political forces
disrupted the administration 2020 well
the right doesn't think that was
legitimate did we have an election then
no 2016 was disputed by the Democrats
2020 is disputed by the Republicans and
right now Democrats are actively
admitting they're actively sabotaging
and admitting to sabotaging the 2024
election in every way from the
Democratic primary to the Republican
primary they are saying to our faces
they are going to burn the system to the
ground there's no election well did you
see at at his uh his uh like
pro-abortion themed rally in Virginia
today Joe Biden opened up by going hello
Virginia and hello to the real governor
of Virginia Terry mcfi I don't know if
I'm saying his name right but it's it's
like if if Trump had done that in a
state where it had been a contentious
election everyone would be like election
deny here and I know there are some
Republicans doing that now mcalli thank
you I was like maffy it's like when I'm
writing it switch all the letters around
shout out to Chris Garr for being a
great editor uh but there is this moment
where it's sort of more Brazen it's okay
when we do it and it seems to be
escalating and this is the same rally
where there were like 14 Interruption by
Pro Palestine protesters during I mean
there were four in the first five
minutes so it's there is Discord all
around but there's definitely a a moment
in my opinion where people who vote
Democrat are sort of looking at the
party and saying do we believe you and
do we represent you and do you actually
know what we want out of you and I think
in some ways the interesting part about
Trump's candidacy is it was a reckoning
of there is a huge population in this us
who want certain things like border
border security they want you to address
the fentanyl crisis they want you to
take on certain issues that to be fair
the Republican uh sort of Old Guard just
didn't take seriously because it didn't
seem to affect them they didn't take it
seriously and I think the um the
American leftist didn't take it
seriously they didn't think that uh you
it's it's like that we have a total
disconnect in again the nature of
reality here and we do in so many cases
you have a bunch of people in the United
States saying that men are women that's
just insane it's obviously insane you
have Joe Biden saying that the border is
closed and that Congress needs to do
something to act to to close the border
but everyone knows full well that
Congress has absolutely no power right
now right I mean even if Congress passed
something the Senate's not going to take
it up Joe Biden would not sign any bill
that actually closed the Border it just
would not happen but I I will say this
though um the Democrats and I I despise
what they stand for but they they they
actually fought for what they believe in
the they have shut this country down
before and you know we have a bunch of
in my opinion spawn jelly back Ros
representing Us in Congress right now
who are just can you just say that again
spinless jelly back Ros and they can
they continue to just give them whatever
they want instead of holding the lawn
it's like our our country's being
invaded right now who cares if we end up
shutting the Border down in order to to
secure funding for that or to to close a
border in some some way thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net